what we're trying to do is to take this
big iron machine this big MRI machine
and reduce it into a consumer
electronics wearable and that can
transform medical imaging and it can
also transform the way we communicate
with each other via brain and and let me
take you on this journey and explain to
you why I think so I believe that we can
put the functionality of that MRI system
into a wearable into a ski hat or a
bandage or a bra or many different
things that gives not just MRI
resolution but read/write and higher
resolution at massively lower cost
not just in 10x lower cost like with one
laptop per child but at scale 1,000
times cheaper which can be really
transformative and so why does that
dovetail not just with medical imaging
but understanding our brains because our
brains are part of our body so if we can
see inside of our body we can see inside
of our brains and there's a lot of great
work that I'm going to share with you
tonight by these amazing neuro
scientists using functional magnetic
resonance imaging scanners those are
like the video form of MRI showing all
kinds of things that we can communicate
by just lying inside of these machines
so the National Academies have said of
the top 5 of most the National Academies
of most developed countries have said of
the top 5 things you can do as a
technologist reverse engineering the
brain is one of those things and so the
question is you know how do you do that
so in the last two-and-a-half years
I'm not a neuroscientist I've talked to
a lot of neuroscientists any
neuroscientist worth their salt will
tell you we don't even know what a
thought is like well you know sort of
like pornography you know when you see
it but we don't know what it is
and this whole issue boils down to
something they call causal versus non
causal you have about a hundred billion
neurons in your brain each of them with
a hundred thousand possible connections
and it just seems intractable to track
that and that's just the neurons let
alone the glia and whatever's happening
in your gut and the hormones and all of
this stuff going on and then there's the
non-causal approach where you just do a
top-down approach which is really I
think what's happened with some of the
both the implant solutions and the fMRI
solutions and so I think that there's
this context that that you know the
Bottoms Up approach is pretty cool but
the top-down approach is also pretty
cool and hopefully we meet in the middle
and so I want to talk to you about a
little bit about what's been done with
fMRI in 1991 got the cover of science a
group at Harvard Mass General Hospital
was able to show that the blood flow of
your brain as measured in an fMRI
machine could show whether you were
looking at an image or not
first thing amazing oh my gosh can we
use fMRI to see thoughts well if we fast
forward a number of years later I became
aware of this work this is the work of
Professor Jack gallant at University of
California at Berkeley and he started
working with lab rats and then macaques
and then moved up to using graduate
students as lab rats and put them in MRI
scanners for hundreds of hours and made
them watch youtube videos where
recordings were made of their minds
lighting up or not lighting up area by
area
what fMRI measures is oxygen use by
looking at the color change or the
change of blood properties whether it's
carrying oxygen or not under two under a
huge magnetic field and by looking at at
that and creating a library if you will
of students reacting to hundreds of
hours of YouTube videos then a new clip
was shown called the presented clip here
and the computer using the scan data
inferred what it thought the student was
looking at and the result is a grainy
image of what the student was looking at
and I saw this and I'm like oh my gosh
we just have to lower the the size of
the device and up the resolution and
there you go and
I tried I tried to get Google to fund
this I tried to get Facebook anyway I am
doing it now and it started so it's been
a long haul and you know also there's
this Japanese group who went even
further they put the graduate students
in the MRI machines and woke the
students up a couple of minutes after
they fell asleep ask them what they were
dreaming about to make a video of your
dream so that you can dump your dreams
in an MRI scanner to the computer it's
totally cool this is back to UC Berkeley
and with less than 5 percent false
positive threshold by looking at an area
or a signature of your brain we can
predict a word cloud of words you're
thinking in this case numbers in another
case there's a there's a violence area
sex and violence area so you could
actually in the future imagine turning
that filter down if you didn't wish to
communicate thoughts of sex and violence
now that you know you're working your
brains up with each other so this is
pretty cool stuff and there's there's
some work done this work is a decade ago
this is just a very fast path through
fMRI where the students were shown a
thousand images and the computer could
if the students were shown each of the
thousand images just twice with 80%
accuracy the fMRI machine and the
computer could decide or gas or infer
what the student what student what the
images the student was looking at and
just to be clear through random gas with
a thousand images that's a point one
percent chance of happening this is
pretty stunning how accurate you can get
in certain control in certain situations
just using fMRI so then there's a lot of
work that's gone on with with brain
implants and it's got to be pretty tough
for you to have the brain implant um has
anybody ever had brain surgery and uh
room I have okay so I the only startup
doing brain computer communication
that's not doing implement in plants I
had a non-elected brain surgery in 1995
to stay alive but
dozen medications every day to live
you're gonna do that if it's that or
deaf but I just don't see a billion
people having elective brain surgery
anytime soon it's the hardest thing I
ever did in my life but yet you know
here's a case at Brown University my
alma mater where a woman was a
paraplegic they gave her an implant and
for the first time she could give
herself a drink with a robot arm totally
cool so if you've got a condition where
you can tree or lock in or you can't
move I totally see it there's been this
amazing work done with electrode probes
where 500 neurons were activated in this
in this primate and with those 500
neurons
activating the electrical pulses the
primate could play the video game and do
pretty well and then they gave the the
hooked 3 primates together each with 500
neuro 500 electrodes and the three
primates played the video games a lot
better which is really kind of
interesting if you think of where that
where that might lead it was sharing our
minds and so the bet we're making I'm
making is that the massively more data
we enable by putting a 2-ton magnet
that's the most expensive room in the
hospital that costs a few million
dollars that has liquid helium to cool
it in a power plant to run it on the
magnetic shielding and no metal and all
of that we put that into a wearable we
can get massively more data higher
resolution and which I'm going to talk
about how with better temporal response
and we also have found and I'm going to
talk a little bit about non-invasive
actually direct neuron read/write and
better hierarchical algorithms that we
think we can develop with us non
causally sort of top-down meeting the
bottom-up people who are saying we don't
know what a thought is there's a hundred
billion neurons each with a hundred
thousand different connections we hear
you we also think it's important to come
top-down